thank you for the chance to speak here
and uh
this is a
joint result with merc halam who is
now at university of washington it was
used to be my
student at simon fraser
and it's about
like classical communication complexity
i guess as
classy i mean more classical than most
of the talks
here there won't be
much fancy
things but i still have to say what the
setup is so it's the most classical
thing it's a two-party
communication complexity there is always
and bob they want to compute a function
half of the input is known to alice the
other half is known to bob
and they exchange some messages
and well it's they're randomized
model of course
and i assume they have joined random
source so
for free they can use the same random
source
and they want to output
correct output with some probability say
at least three quarters
and the goals so there are two goals
one is the standard goal of minimizing
the communication and
the second that maybe not so standard or
not
as
often studied is to minimize the number
of rounds
so in this
number of messages they send
and but these are conflicting goals
sometimes so you're looking for a
possible trade-off between them
so if
you can minimize the number of runs
without
increasing the total communication is
great if not then there might be some
kind of trade-off between them
okay
so
what are the two main examples that were
studied many
last i don't know three decades
sadly join us and
equality
so
they look similar but we know that they
behave very differently
so in
in the sad disjointness
there is the classical result of kalina
sunderham and schnittger
that basically you cannot do better than
the trivial protocol one has to send the
entire input
and the for the equality
just
two bits in one round is enough
so you cannot
beat that
so one is very easy one is very hard and
of course
this has been studied for so long there
is not much to say about these two
problems
uh but surprisingly there is something
to say about close relatives of these
problems
so one of the things i will say
is already
mentioned this afternoon we will see
that
but the main point is that we consider
variants of these problems and the first
variant is offset disjointness so
instead the jointness you have a base
set
age of and elements the players get
subsets they want to decide if they are
disjoint or not
and the variant of that is the sparse or
small set disjointness
it's the same
problem exactly except you restrict the
input so you say that okay they get
subsets but this subset should be small
it only makes sense if they are very
smaller than the
size of the universe
and of course
hit this arrow here
it's outside
so
clearly if you want to decide the
joyness on the k um k size universe
that's contained in this problem and the
full disjointness problem in size and
universe is also contained in it
so
the complexity therefore
of the varsa disjoin us
well it's at least
omega of k form the lower bound
at least at most order of n from the
upper bound that doesn't mean much but
even the trivial protocol is better than
that it's k times log n
so if k is much less than n then it's
already better you can even get uh k low
k bound with the trivial reduction of
the size of the universe you can assume
that the size of the universe is say
quadratic in k
and then this became so all these are
band-around protocols
so you can solve sparse disjointness by
one round protocol
with say o k lo k bits
and
so this this is the theorem that we
we're already that was already mentioned
this afternoon hostile and victorious on
prove that well actually you can do it
in order of k bits
so
this this log factor is not needed
uh
that's a
date is a bit funny i mean they they
actually announced it like 10 years
earlier and then this is when it was
published
so
okay so what uh
so this is optimal i mean obviously i
cannot improve on this result because uh
this is optimal so what can i add so
uh first when he when actually mert was
starting to work on this he wanted to i
mean consider the other
other parameter that i mentioned not
just the
communication but also the number of
rounds so that if you want to minimize
the number of rounds
and then
so if you also consider that then this
is the original hosted vector zone
protocol so its order of k bits which is
optimal it has log k or order of low k
rounds
and they prove the constant error that's
not a big deal i mean they could have
proved exponentially small error or two
if they wanted
but this is how our result
compared to it we
uh
decrease the number of rounds
substantially substantially for
from logarithmic to lock star so log
star is how many times you apply log to
kill a number
and exponentially small errors so
this is uh
it's nice i mean
we don't pay anything for reducing so
there is no trade-off yet
we went from logarithmic number of
rounds to lockstar rounds and we didn't
have to pay for that
uh
but
the important or the well
the
hard part here is to prove that this is
actually optimal you cannot go below
lock star without paying for it
and
there's nothing less than log stuff
oh yeah because there's a
well constant is less than log star
right
well i mean i can come up with like
square of log style or whatever but
but the constant is uh
that's an interest i mean
okay so that's very interesting
trade-offs comes in and that was the
mathematically hard part of uh
for result is to prove that lok styrus
died and this trade-off that i will show
is also tied for any number of rounds
below lockstar
but i also
we also found something funny or
whatever something that is
nice and that's uh
that's this
uh
that
the hosta victory zone protocol just
gives a zero one output and that's
that's what's required right i mean you
ask whether two sets are disjoint i mean
they are either disjoint or not they
join that's a one bit output
uh but with the
uh
tweaking or
our protocol we can
actually output the actual intersection
without paying more so it's still order
of k bits and
lock star k rounds you can
ask how i can output an intersection
when even outputting it is
is more than
uh
over there of k bits so if the universe
is like huge intersection can be like
size k half
so i don't i mean that's kind of
cheating it's not the output i mean the
players will know
i mean for them it's not a big deal i
mean they already have a size k set that
contains the intersection so for them
it's just over there of k bits to know
what is the intersection they will know
i mean
uh for an outside they're looking at the
transcript they cannot possibly know
because the transcript is too small to
tell the entire intersection but that's
still nice i mean the players themselves
will know the intersection
okay and this is the trade-off that i
said i we had
so
imagine that you have r rounds r is now
less than log star so it's better to
think of r as a constant because as we
know there is nothing less than log star
but constants
and then you will have to pay for that
instead of k bits you will have to pay
k times
r times iterated log of k
in communication
for that
and that's also optimal so for any given
r
this is optimal uh so
it's a tata actually
uh so you see that
where the logs start coming from i mean
if you put log star here then this is
just a constant
and therefore you are still that order
of k
and
um
if you want to make this as a lower
bound on the number of rounds if you
insist on order of k bits then you get
that log star minus order of one is the
correct answer of course if you put log
star minus 2 here then it's still order
of k that's fine
okay so that's the tight bound
uh
so this has three parts basically
one is this free
reduction on the number of rounds that's
really very easy it's just a one
sentence trick
this nice observation that you can
actually find the intersection that's
another idea but i can hopefully convey
that and the mathematically deepest part
is of course in this lower bound and i
will show
the least of that i try to and i have
some slides on that
but i won't have time to go into the
details there
okay so before we do that
i
want to
go back to the host advice zone protocol
it's a very nice and simple protocol
and that's what we use i mean i mean our
contribution for the upper bound is just
a very
small
tiny tweak in this protocol
so this is the protocol
alice has x
and picks a random set as zero that
contains s i will tell you later how she
picks that
sends that over
and now they know that the intersection
must be inside this set because well x
is inside this set
so
bob will know that the intersection is
actually
in the intersection of his set and s
node
clearly
wherever there is an intersection it
must be in this so his next message is
just a random set containing that so
this random set s1
contain the intersection
he sends over that message and this kind
of repeats so now alice knows that the
intersection is
well in s1 and in her set
and finds a random subset containing
that sends that over and so forth
where does it end
so
these are the sets sent over back and
forth
and they stop if
the current set is empty so the current
set is all the inter so for alice the
current set is the all the intersection
of the sets that
were sent back and forth because they
all contain the intersection plus the
intersection of x also
if that happens to be empty then she
knows that there is no way there is
anything in the intersection
intersection must be empty so they stop
and and announce that the sets are
disjoint and this is a one
sided error thing so there is no error
in this announcement here
and otherwise
they just stop and in and
say intersect
if
they run out of time and they can run
out of time in run out of time in two
different ways either the number of
rounds are exhausted so instead of over
there of low k i should specify like 100
low k rounds
nothing happens then they stop
or if like 200k bits are already used up
then they
then they stop so that's the protocol
but i didn't tell you how these random
sets are selected and sent over
uh obviously you don't want to send the
entire
set
so these random sets are coming from the
joint random source so there is like a
list of random subsets of age
these are uniform independent random
subsets and whenever somebody has to
send
a random subset containing something
he or she will send the
next
random subset in the index of the next
random subset
and that
that is good that contains so for the
first set
uh alice has to pick a set that contains
x
well
he looks at the first index such that
that
index random set contains x and the uh
good thing is that the expected number
of bits she will send is the is exactly
well approximately or expect expectation
it's the
it's the size of x i mean any
any random set will contain x with
probability
well one over two to the size of x
so
in probably one of the first two to the
size of x sets one of them will be good
so she will have to send this many bits
so what happens
is
well i already told that the
this is a one-sided there or protocol so
no error for intersecting sets
so we only have to worry about this
joint set so imagine that there are two
disjoint sets x and y are disjoint
and then whenever
messages are sent back and forth
what you expect is that uh
this current set is halved i mean you
just get
basically you intersect it with a random
set
and a random set will in expectation
half the size of your current set
so
of course
you have to bound the arrow probably
whatever but in a high level it's clear
that for most of the time
in
low k rounds
uh
you will arrive to the empty set
and uh
where the first round you already used
up k bits then the second round you
already using gap k half bits because
your set is already half that big
so
there is like a exponential decrease in
the bits you use up in every round so
all together you just use up order of k
bits
so that's the halstad victory zone
protocol
uh so i promise that uh
yeah
okay
expected round and okay and k bits
so
our tweak on this is just a very
small tweak
we use bias random sets so instead of
taking a random set that is a uniform
set
we take a random set that is not uniform
it is
a small set
which is achieved by taking every
element independently with some
probability p and p will be very small
and that's good on one side because it's
quicker uh in decreasing the so if you
if i give you a random set with this
bias speeder
and you're intersecting your own set
with that
then from size k you go directly to size
p times k in expectation
which is uh
that's good
if p small that's much less than k half
but you have to pay for it
it's harder to find so whenever i'm
sending a message that's like a random
set containing
my current set
and if my current set is x
then
i have to wait longer
before i find the set that contains it
and they this is how much you have to
wait
so this is how many bits you will send
in expectation
and the good thing is that
the thing that you gain is p and the
thing that you pay for is just look one
over p
so
that's kind the exponential advantage
uh so as your cells get closer i mean
smaller and smaller you can afford
um very high i mean much higher bias
every every round your bias will be
uh p that is smaller and smaller and
that's the optimal trade-off
every next p will be exponential in the
previous p
and that's where log star is coming in
and the iterated log and everything so
that's just the
high level overview but this is
basically everything there is to it
so
by tweaking the protocol with this
biased random set
again you are not paying for those
random set they are coming from the
joint random source so they are free
only only paying for finding the first
one that is good for your purposes
and well there you pay this much
so this is the tweak on the house dot
viktorizon protocol that reduces
the number of rounds
and of course it also gives you the
trade-off if
if you are willing to
send a bit longer messages then you can
start with a very small p already in the
first round
and then the constant number of rounds
will be enough so it gives you all the
upper bounds that i mentioned and really
there is not much into it
so this is uh
uh
observing actually disappeared in i
guess in fox
13 i guess
uh but back then we didn't know that
we can find the intersection so that
that came later
but that's very nice so
i tell
i will tell you how to find the
intersection
so
the trick is that
well
the known trick is that you try to do
the same thing you try to
send
forget about the bias you're just
sending back and forth this random set
containing the current set that is
containing whatever can be still in the
intersection
why is this infeasible
because
so
it almost works
but
but here is the problem so
that's the universe
here is x here is y and there is this
big intersection now
so this can be size k or k half or
something
and whenever uh alice sends a set that
will contain x so it will probably have
the rest of the y
but
the current set will always include this
intersection
so
you can't
use the argument so the number of rounds
will be the same and whatever but the
rounds will be longer you cannot really
uh
expect an exponential decrease
in the size of the current set because
now the size i mean that size will never
go below the size of the true
intersection
so
so it looks like a problem
and the good part
is that
so there is this true intersection part
this is the intersection of x and y
and the rest will really decrease as you
would expect i mean if you don't do the
biases
then it will basically half every time
so whatever you have outside the true
intersection
that
behaves nicely
so
what you have is that
if you
so look at alice's view of the whole
thing
so he has
this
her set x
and after like 10 rounds he still has
this very big set remaining
so the next set will probably not have
it
because
it's probably most of it is already the
intersection
so she knows what to expect she has a
lot of information about the next set
coming she knows how much it will cut
away from her set
and we can use that so we can use that
the decrease we know that the decrease
will be small so after a few rounds what
you have is almost the intersection
there are just a couple of more elements
to that you have to get rid of so every
set that cuts off
more than that is not very likely that
it will be bob's message so what's but
what will do is
she'll look for the next random
set
that
contains his current set
uh but sending the index over would be a
waste it's too long
so he just sends a couple of bits from
the index and that will be enough for
alice she will know that okay so this
might mean
a couple of possible uh sets that bob
really meant and she will go for the one
where that cuts away from her sets the
smallest amount and that will with high
likelihood it will be correct
so
we can kind of maintain
uh that the message size
is not corresponding to the entire
intersection but just the part of the
alice's current set that is not the true
intersection
so that's the protocol for finding the
intersection
well
the
um
sketch of the protocol anyway
and just a few problem few words about
the lower bound before we go to the
lower bound
um there is this related problem the
equality
we know that
it has a two-bit single-round solution
but there is a version of that the exist
equal problem which is a parallel
repetition version of that so they or
direct some version if you want so all
these gets like k inputs bob gets like k
inputs
and
they want to solve the equality problem
for all of them well they don't really
they just want to solve the ore of this
problem of of this k equality problem so
they have a large
string
alice's and bob has also a large string
and they want to decide there is at
least one position where the two strings
are equal
and that's a special case of spar set
this joint us
so you can
build this uh
set of pairs alice can build a set of
pairs both can build a set of pairs and
the quality happens
if these two sets are not disjoint so
solving this part said this joyner's
problem solves
uh the existing call problem and you
have the same balance so you can solve
it
with lock star runs and order of k bits
or
even fewer bits with some iterated log
extra cost
and this is still optimal for ner and
i'm telling you this for two reasons one
is because all the lower bounds are for
the exists equal problem
and it's a direct uh
where is it
so
it's an elementary argument for
single round protocols you get that k
lok k of the basically the trivial
protocol is optimal and around the
elimination argument in general and that
involves
some i mean
entropies and mutual information and
whatever that but the most important
part is an isometric iso parametric
equality on the heming cube
so
you are asking for
like the most compact set but
the way we defined compact is sun is not
standard so we kind of had to build that
is a parametric inequality ourselves
so this is how we measure compactness so
take a random
ball
so with the fixed radius but around the
random point
and intersect it with your set
take the logarithm of that and take the
expected
uh
size
what is t t is some extent
what is t to the t so when you take the
t is the universe for the equality
problem so when you take the exist equal
problem you have this and that's the
important parameter how many equality
problems you have to solve and there is
another parameter how big those equality
problems are
so the number of uh
or
you have the order of k questions
or of yeah so k then k k and n are the
same
and t is t is just uh the universe for
the equality problem so a a ladder for
the equality problem is coming from a
universe of size t
so maybe i should have wrote like n to
the k and then it's more consistent with
what i said earlier
here are the expectations over x and h
in uh
in the entire entire humming cube
so that's agreed it's like uh
t by t by t by t
grid
and you add your averaging is over the
entire grid but you want to make sure
that this is never empty right
yeah well
maybe you add plus one too
yeah yeah you're right if it's zero i
took the logarithm of zero and that's a
big no no i shouldn't have done that but
it's basically good
that's the radius of the ball
so the radius of the ball is depends on
so that's a fixed parameter so it's
fixed for the entire
um
it will be basically proportional to the
dimension like one
like n over 100 or something like that
anyway i'm running out of time so i just
have uh
this
question what what are the things that
actually achieve that so so we didn't
really solve the eyes of parametric
inequality
we have a lower bound that you cannot be
more compact than and the number but uh
but is the most compact that depends on
on how big the size is sometimes it's a
face of the cube so yeah like you fix a
couple of coordinates
sometimes it's the
opposite like
the complement of that i mean
it really changes and we didn't we
didn't find didn't find the optimal
solution
no it's it doesn't tend to be the
hamming ball it's it's more like you fix
a couple of coordinates and
so but this is a nice
observation it's not very surprising but
i finished my talk with this
it was a bit surprising for us so
you can solve a single in a equality
problem with 10 bits in a single round
maybe you want to still use a single
round or maybe just like a bounded
number of rounds like three rounds
and because of her lower bound you need
more than
so you
you want to solve the or of k equalities
and uh
the the direct sum question is how this
relates to like k times is it smaller
than you need really k times that much
in uh
um
k times that much communication or not
turns out that that's not the right
question you need more than k times that
much
for one round you need k times low k
bits for two rounds you need k log log k
bits and well that's not really
surprising because if you really solve
that with one
tenth of a percent of an error every
uh
if k is large and you solve each
instance with that much error and it
kind of adds up and there will be an
error somewhere so i mean if you want to
solve it in one round then you better
solve it uh with the
order of one over k error and then
suddenly solving a single problem takes
slow k bits and it's okay okay so it's
just surprising that it's more than a
linear increase for linear number of
repetitions thank you
okay are there any questions yeah
what happens in the case of zero error
how does your result compare to
expected
communication
zero error expected communication
so
i think uh
it does i mean it does work with zero
error i mean not defining the
intersection part doesn't but
but just reducing the number of rounds
it works the same way i think
for the uh finding the intersection
there will be all kind of errors coming
in when you didn't guess right which
message was sent i mean bob sent some
said and you didn't guess right we sent
we set his hand and all kinds of error
will come in and we cannot make it zero
error
let's take this figure again